pour réussir le noël des izonnais il
faut des bras en cuisine
le bataillon des bénévoles est déjà à la
tâche l'ambiance est studieuse et
appliquée antonin supervise le gros
c'est du pain perdu avec les différents
gâteaux apéritifs qui accompagneront ce
pain pas lieu à table pour que tout soit
prêt en temps et en heure il faut
commencer de bonheur attention passage
des ans très attendu deux heures de
préparation pour des entrées qui seront
servis en dix minutes
ça c'est l'entrée de ce soir donc ça
sera de la terrine de saumon à l'oseille
accompagné de citron et de tomates une
entrée de fait on mange pas tous les
jours du sommet le plat de résistance et
du filets de chapon accompagné d'un duo
de carros et de panais et de un
millefeuille de champignons d'un plateau
de fromages avec du gris du camembert
et alors le dessert ça sera un sultan à
la fraise et chocolat dans la grande
salle
c'est la même effervescence chacun est
arc-boutée sur son travail de décoration
le thème de 2019 les jeux anciens
les bénévoles ne ménagent ni leur temps
ni leur peine
encore moins leur enthousiasme on vit
dans une société où l'individualisme est
roi noël ses engagements envers les
autres et d'apporter un peu dead et
d'apporter ne serait ce qu'un peu
d'altruisme en verre en vers ceux qui en
ont besoin
noël des isolés c'est un élan de
générosité l'appel du coeur
la magie de noël le soir de noël la fête
de famille faire une famille assure une
grande famille annoncera 200 une grande
famille mais c'est tellement beau vous
savez et enrichissant pour tout le monde
l'association vit entièrement sur ses
deniers
elle sait pouvoir compter sur ses
bénévoles et sur des donateurs